well we do a lot of research in schools
so we we study schools we help schools
to understand how they need to change by
helping them to become clear on what the
problems are we think it's very
important that before you go a reformer
school or change your school that you
clear what the problem is that you make
sure that the remedy matches the problem
which sounds like common sense but
unfortunately that doesn't happen enough
so so it's very important to give
teachers principals a real clear sense
of what they need to focus on in order
to get better results
PS 12 that I mentioned before they have
a great data person who can give
teachers very precise data on each and
every one of their students so they know
exactly what they need to work on that's
very important if we don't want teachers
to be more effective what they do
the alternative is guesswork and
guesswork doesn't work that well
I see lots of examples you know I see
schools that are using smart boards now
very effectively I barely understand
lose myself still but I'm impressed but
when I see them being used as a part of
instruction because it makes it much
more interactive and the kids seem to
respond extremely well because you know
this is like they're working with
computers and video games all the time I
was visiting the classroom the other day
where a teacher was using video games to
teach history lesson and kids were
totally engaged there's a math program
I've been working with now called FG and
it it allowed that the software allows
that it can figure out what the student
doesn't understand and take them
backwards
so it can figure out what they what they
did learn and then build a foundation
back up and the software's doing that so
the what it does is it gives the
children the ability have more control
over learning which is I think what we
really want so there are a lot of
examples of good technology out there I
always say the most important thing is
to make sure that teachers are
comfortable with using the technology in
many schools the children um are more
comfortable with it than the adults and
that's a problem students would rather
watch a big thing video then sit and
read a long page of text in a textbook
they have an opportunity to get the
information that they wouldn't
necessarily otherwise have we're using
the technologies to connect to learn
students can participate by using the
Internet to their advantage